ponerle barreras flotantes al mar un
intento por contener y ralentizar los
flujos de petróleo tras el masivo
derrame de crudo frente a las costas del
sur de california en tierra con las
playas cerradas centenares de personas
trabajan a contrarreloj en las tareas de
recuperación y salvamento de la vida
silvestre wickens jennifer en gris
seguimos aumentando nuestro personal en
el puesto de mando de incidentes así
como nuestro personal sobre el terreno
hemos duplicado con creces el nivel de
esfuerzo sólo desde ayer y estas cifras
seguirán aumentando es numbers boca oa
las autoridades y la compañía dueña de
la plataforma amplified están
investigando si el ancla de un barco
pudo haber sido el desencadenante del
vertido al golpear el oleoducto
submarino que ha provocado el derrame de
más de 570 mil litros de petróleo y una
catástrofe medioambiental
la prioridad número uno en este momento
es salvar a los animales y salvar la
vida silvestre esa es la preocupación
número uno pero lo que todo el mundo
quiere saber es quién es el responsable
y como ha ocurrido quién va a pagar por
ello y quién será considerado
responsable pons mo mientras observa en
la gigantesca mancha negra sobre el mar
los residentes piden explicaciones
es una catástrofe ocurre todo el tiempo
una y otra vez y hay muchas cosas que
deberíamos hacer al respecto los grupos
ambientalistas llevan años presionando
para que eeuu inicia una transición de
las explotaciones petroleras hacia las
energéticas renovables y evitar así este
tipo de desastres medioambientales